PRIYANKA VERGADIA: If you are
ingesting large amounts of data
for analysis or
looking to simplify
the development of event
driven microservices,
then you need to check
out Cloud Pub/Sub.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to Pub/Sub Made Easy.
I'm Priyanka.
And in today's episode, we will
dive deeper into Subscribers.
A publisher sent messages
to a Cloud Pub/Sub topic.
Subscriber application creates
a subscription to this topic
in order to receive
those messages.
A topic can have multiple
subscriptions but a given
subscription belongs
to a single topic,
which means a subscription
cannot be receiving messages
from more than one topics.
Check out episode
2 of the series
to see how to set
up subscriptions.
Cloud Pub/Sub delivers each
published message at least once
for every subscription.
There are some exceptions to
this at least once behavior
though.
You can configure message
retention duration.
And the value can be between
10 minutes and seven days.
By default, a message that
cannot be delivered within
the maximum retention time of
seven days is deleted and is no
longer accessible.
This typically happens when
a subscriber does not keep up
with the flow of the messages.
Oh, and make sure to create
at least one subscription
when you create a topic.
Otherwise, the
messages published
to the topic with
no subscription
disappear into the ether.
Once a message is
sent to a subscriber,
the subscriber should
acknowledge the message.
But until it does, the message
is considered outstanding.
And it stays outstanding
until the subscriber
reaches the configurable
limited amount of time
called ACT deadline,
at which point
Cloud Pub/Sub will
attempt to redeliver it.
And while the message is
outstanding to a subscriber,
Cloud Pub/Sub tries
not to deliver it
to any other subscriber
on the same subscription.
Typically, Cloud Pub/Sub
delivers each message once
in the order in which
it was published.
However, messages may
sometimes be delivered out
of order or more than once.
Idempotency and duplication
is important to think
about regardless of Pub/Sub
since it can happen simply
because publishers
republish the same content.
A very simple way to achieve
exactly once processing
is to rely on Cloud Dataflow's
Pub/Sub I/O connector which
solves some of the harder
problems like this for you.
You can also achieve
ordered processing
by having the publishers
send the sequence
token in the message.
Stay tuned for more on this
in the upcoming episodes.
Alternatively, Cloud Dataflow
gives you very simple
to use tools to produce
ordered output or process
messages in order.
Now a subscription can use
either pull or push mechanism
for message delivery.
And it's configurable.
So you can change or configure
the mechanism at any time.
In pull delivery, the
subscribing application
explicitly calls the
pull method which
requests messages for delivery.
The Cloud Pub/Sub
server responds
with a message or an
error if the queue
is empty and an Ack ID.
The subscriber explicitly
calls the acknowledged method
using the returned Ack ID
to acknowledge receipt.
A lot of this is abstracted
in the client libraries
where you might simply create
callbacks that are invoked
when a new message arrives.
The client library
itself will manage
all the acknowledgment
deadlines and extensions.
In push delivery, the
Cloud Pub/Sub servers
sends each message
as an HTTPS request
to the subscriber application
at a pre-configured endpoint.
The endpoint
acknowledges the message
by returning an HTTP
success status code.
A nonsuccess response
indicates that the message
should be resent.
Cloud Pub/Sub dynamically
adjusts the rate
of push requests based
on the rate at which it
receives success responses.
Now that we know how push
and pull subscriptions work,
how can we choose
which method should
be best for our use case?
Well, stay tuned for the
next episode to find out.
Now let's talk about the
lifecycle of subscription.
By default, subscription expires
after 31 days of inactivity.
Inactivity can be no
active connections,
pull requests, or
push successes.
If Cloud Pub/Sub detects
subscriber activity,
the subscription
deletion clock restarts.
But by using subscription
expiration policies,
you can configure the
inactivity duration
or make the
subscription persistent
regardless of activity.
You can also delete a
subscription manually.
And if you create a
subscription with the same name
as the deleted one,
the new subscription
has no relationship
with the old one.
Today be learned how to
subscribe to Cloud Pub/Sub
messages.
We looked at least once
delivery, push, and pull
methods.
Join us next time to learn more
about choosing between push
and pull subscribers.
If you liked this
video and would
like to see more
such content, don't
forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]